this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Thursday the 27th of
the month I think don't [__] quote me
on that the joint is brought to you by
Blue Jew listen the temperature's
dropping but your dick is going to go
through the roof with our next sponsor
Bluetooth
is online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but an a chewable tablet all at a
fraction of the cost take the many time
and be ready for when the opportunity
arises AKA when you see a pigeon on the
pond the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
is taught that online no doctors visits
no awkward conversations no dick
Bluetooth tablets are made in the US of
a and sheep and shipped in a discreet
package so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to sling
dick blue shoe can help try Bluetooth
for free when using promo code Joey I'm
talking about free when using promo code
Joey just pay five dollars for shipping
that's it this is your gift from Uncle
joy for Halloween trick or treat
[__] Bluetooth
dot com code Joey for your life for your
first month free visit bluetooth.com for
more important safety information and I
want to thank blue shoe for sponsoring
the podcast oh my God the joint is also
brought to you by display add some class
to any room in your house they got
millions of designs available featuring
gaming movies and comics and they have
licensed designs from Star Wars Netflix
shows and many more listen I got the
Bruce Lee one it's [__] smoking it
takes 20 seconds to hang a display no
power tools no drills no [__] damages
once you mount one you could switch it
out for a new plate and the Flash with
everyone that you buy display plants a
tree click the link in the description
to see many of my favorite displays and
save up to 29 get 25 off when you buy
one or two but if you buy three or more
to get you 29 off discounts will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click or use code Joey go to
display they got some tremendous prints
and you're going to love them you hang
them you take them down you switch them
around that's displayed.com code Joey or
click into the link in the show notes
the joint is also brought to you by my
favorite I had to talk about them this
week manscape is here so you can keep
your little candy corn smooth this
Halloween listen this week I trimmed my
ball head my chest hair my nut hair just
the hair on my dick pole [__] Tip Top
Magoo I had like an afro grown down
there it's over no cuts no [__]
chafing no itching that's manscape
performance package they got everything
the lawnmower the trim your nuts the
weed whacker the trim your nose and the
e-head trimmer to get the [__] ear
rocks out of the ears they offer skin
safe technology to protect your delicate
[__] holes and it's waterproof so you
can [__] trim your nut sack and your
eyebrows and your nose hairs in the
[__] shower you filthy [__]
manscape even threw in two free gifts to
that package boxes and the shed travel
bag with a little secret compartment in
between get 20 off in free
[Music]
[__] best [__] product out there and
your balls need to be [__] taken care
of how many more times do women have to
look at you with that look on their face
like you just [__] farted even though
you got a butt plug in your ass I'm
Gonna Get You 20 off and free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com manscape
clear out the leaves it's your tree
trunks time to shine let's get this
[__] body started [__]
foreign
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here it's Thursday the 20
whatever the [__] it is I don't even
know anymore you know listen the last
couple for years we did them on Mondays
and Wednesdays but you know what it's
time to shake things up a little bit I
think I want to keep [__] Thursdays
it's uh better for my schedule I'm happy
and Mike is happy we don't have to rush
back in here two days later and come up
with [__] to talk about and uh I just
feel a lot better doing it it's been a
great week so far I went to Princeton
longevity Center if you have a parent or
a grandparent that is kind of [__] up
like me and you want to get to the
bottom of what's going on with that
[__] send them to Princeton
longevity Center all jokes aside the
doctors were great
it's like a [__] old all-day camp
of your everything is about you you go
in there first thing they do they don't
even talk they hit you with a covert
test then they hit you with a [__] uh
they take out like 18 tubes of blood I
did not pass out and then from there you
go to a [__] other room and they
stick a whatevering an intravenous thing
and then they put ink in you and they do
your [__] heart then from there they
put you on another table and they
measure your bone density and all this
[__] then from there they put you in
another [__] table and they screen
your whole body a full body [__]
screen then you go into the room and you
eat your little snack they add some [__]
to eat but Papa bought a grilled cheese
with avocados you got to keep that
saturated fat good I brought a little
[__] Coke Zero and then you go back
again and now you sit with the doctor
and he [__] talks to you about it I
had to bring a sheet of [__] paper
with everything that was wrong fungi
toenail my dick smells funny you know
[__] itching this rashes I brought
every [__] thing I could possibly in
there you sit with this [__] for
two hours when was the last time you sat
with your [__] doctor for two hours
go ahead I'll wait never two [__]
hours he went over everything a hernia
we closed up with the finger in the ass
now let me tell you something I usually
don't like the finger in the ass but
it's been four years and when you guys
get older you'll worry about the finger
in the ass on top of that chew [__]
tobacco and I smoke reefer so I piss a
lot so I thought there was something
wrong with my PSA and my [__] colon
bam that [__] stuck the finger
in there while I was in there he goes
Everything feels all right here he
popped that finger out one of those one
of those things that he pulled it out
with the wait let me tell you something
when you got a finger in the ass from a
doctor he puts a glove on so right away
you're like is this you is this [__]
Judas Priest's hand is this a singer
from Judas Priest it's like a little
latex glove and then they put like uh
gay sperm on your finger that don't work
like it's like a Lube then yeah it's
like nah it's not Vaseline it's like a
real lube and when they put it in your
ass you actually hear the loop go like
you hear that trust me the first time I
got a finger in the ass I had to cancel
all appointments for the rest of the day
it was it was mind-boggling because he
was rubbing my back and he just [__]
put it in there without telling me and
it just [__] strike me like you ever
see the ape in trading places when the
guy [__] when the ape [__] the [__]
guy in the ass and his eyes open up but
he ate soup it was just like that I
almost [__] fell off the [__]
table that time I had to cancel
everything and go home and sleep for six
hours from heartbreak and [__] uh you
know depression because when you get a
finger stuff up your ass and it comes
out of nowhere it [__] with your head
but yesterday's finger in the ass let me
tell you something I believe everything
starts with the mind
you got to see it before it happens and
all that [__] I think the same thing
happens when you go for a [__] uh a
random check on your [__] and I'll
tell you why because I I got the call
like Thursday I was gonna go and by
Friday I started having like I felt I
started to feel bloated I took the
protein pot I doubled up on the fiber by
Sunday I felt really bloated Monday I
couldn't even [__] eat dinner I had a
bowl of soup for [__] Monday night
dinner
Tuesday when I went in there I took a
little [__] in the morning just like a
little one it was like a little [__]
cat [__] but let me tell you something
after that doctor stuck the finger up my
ass it was like Moses's finger when he
popped out of my ass and he goes
Everything feels all right now he goes
you get dressed now I go doc we're not
even getting dressed we're going
straight to the [__] bathroom I went
to the bathroom and my ass opened up
like that [__] River motion parted I
must have had eight pounds of [__] in
there and the last piece that came out
of my ass stood up it just stood there I
went to wipe my ass and I bumped into it
my finger I had to get up and wipe my
head and beat that [__] stick down
the goddamn toilet so it was a great day
guys that's what I'm trying to say then
they put you in a [__] visual thing
after that then they test your [__]
hearing after that then they [__]
take you to a gym there's a gym in the
facility and they stretch you they test
your arms they [__] your chest you
lift some weights they put you on a
[__] stress test they do the whole
thing and then the guy gives you like a
pseudo workout and then at the end
everything you go back in you see the
doctor for another [__] hour and he
tells you what you need to do he gives
me prescriptions I got to take an
echocardiogram I got to take a few shots
of monococcal ammonium shot so I don't
get a flu for old people I got to take
the other [__] shot I got a
prescription for some cholesterol [__]
even though my cholesterol was not bad
he says he could use it to work on my
knee arthritis and it'll take away the
knee arthritis a little bit so hey it
was a winning day for everybody but I
got to tell you something
I almost didn't go guys you know I'm a
[__] [__] I woke up my the car was
picking me up the Uber was picking me up
at 7 30. do you know what time I was
awake at 4 30 a.m sitting there you
couldn't drink coffee I couldn't chew
nicotine gum all I could do is sit there
and drink [__] Water by 6 30 I'm like
man I'm gonna cancel this
because I'm never gonna make it
to [__] 8 30. I'm never and it's a 40
minute drive I'm never gonna make it but
I said you know what I'm gonna go in
there try my best
she took out I don't know how many
[__] tubes of blood and
it felt [__] tremendous I didn't
faint I didn't even break a [__]
sweat I had die-hard the hunter on on
[__] my phone I always used to have
Santana that was my [__] official
blood drawing [__] song but my iPod
went [__] dead so I got this uh I got
Pyromania on my phone I got a couple AC
DC albums I think I even got a YouTube
album on my phone that's it so I played
[__] uh Die Hard the Hunter and uh
what's the other Jam that they got after
Die Hard the hunter not too late for
love but stage fright that's a great
[__] jam and that was it I'll tell
you what man when I walked out of there
I felt a hundred percent better like the
[__] I was worried about my lungs the
[__] [__] or
all that stuff I was worried about I'm
good I'm good I thought I had cancer you
know when I went in there they found the
kidney stone but it's a very small small
one
he doesn't want me to worry about there
was a little plaque a little bit of
plaque in my leg a little bit of plaque
towards my heart that's what the thing
is for but guess what we get to Live
Another Day guys I Gotta Lose a little
weight
and uh he said my diet is great all my
numbers were [__] great like on the
blood test it looked a lot better than I
would anticipate like I said 30 years
ago I wouldn't give a [__] about any of
this
but now I got somebody else to think of
so you do what we do and we try our
hardest if it means not just drinking
soda and eat more fruit and having the
salad a day
I guess that's the route we're gonna
have to go until we [__] you know
like I said the other day guys 60 is not
an age
that you should be concerned anymore
it's guys take a look at Tommy Lee and
20 other guys to the [__] 60 and
they're living a life guys I mean look
at these musicians they've gone on the
road 20 years ago you never saw a
[__] musician over 70 really go out
yeah like George Burns with the comedy
who is old but Tony Bennett [__]
picked it up he's like 95 you know Mick
Jagger some of these guys are 78 and are
still [__] touring I think uh Roger
Waters so guys
you gotta love all this [__]
on another note I ended therapy on
Monday like I told you guys it was after
a year and a half
you know man I feel so [__]
hypocritical talking to you guys about
this because
I don't know there was for years I was
very hard-headed and I felt like
if you went to therapy it meant you were
weak like I I that's why I really had a
hard time with it all the time
uh when I was young and I was in the
halfway house they tried therapy on me
and I just get into arguments with this
lady
because it was like she wanted to pick a
scam like that's going to help you in
any way
and then when I went to prison there was
like therapy groups and I could deal
with those you know 45 minutes you
either talk you listen you learn
something either way
but when it's just you and a
psychiatrist I don't know it gave me
the wrong uh
I don't know it just didn't feel right
for me I always said that if you have
good friends
you don't need a [__] psychiatrist
but uh when I got off the [__] plane
I just didn't feel good you know it went
on for a few months
and then I realized what was bothering
me and I took some therapy to help me
chat it out
and there were so many things I thought
I wanted to do with therapy so many
answers I thought I got and after a year
I got to tell you the answer I did get I
mean
the reason why I called the therapist in
the first place was because I had spoken
to a couple of my friends
and at that time I was a little [__]
uh off on the comedy
and I couldn't understand how a person
could put 30 years into something love
something as much as I did be out every
night by seven [__] 30 at night
because they couldn't wait to burn down
a [__] stage
and now uh
you know I'm here uh and I don't want to
do every night I would always check my
sneakers and say well do I want to go
out tonight not really I guess I'm going
to watch TV and smoke some pot and that
lasted a year and a half before I had
any inclination at all of doing stand up
but the reason why I got back to stand
up
was because of that this therapist that
I was speaking to Dana we just went back
and forth about it and she she made me
do homework on it as bad as the sounds
and I went back to stand up through her
to see what I felt she goes let's give
it a [__] test let's see how you feel
if you don't feel good just never go
again
and now I'm to the point Aaron Berg is
down at the uh
Uncle Vinnie's tonight I'm thinking of
going down there and seeing him oh you
know I can't take a date anywhere in
Jersey until my Philadelphia date gets
done so
I just could do little workouts that's
why I haven't booked anything at Uncle
Vinny's not because I won't go down
there so Aaron Burr's down there the
guys from Cobra Kaya down there next
week uh brennerst and the Arab guy did
[__] that show with him not not I
didn't do Cobra Kyle with them I did
another show where I played the meatball
game with him I forget what the name of
that show but Disney XX but uh no she we
set up a deal her and I and she's like I
just want you to go and do 10 minutes
just to see how it feels on her and I
walked hand through hand with this I
didn't tell you guys but in my mind this
is what we were doing
and I would check with her like we
those eight weeks I talked to a every
[__] Monday and we would go over my
plan for the week I'm gonna go out on
Thursday how did you feel last week and
guys this is uh I had to go back to
basics because
I was going there just to pick up a
check
all I cared about was Saturday night
when the promoter handed me a check I
didn't care about really being there all
I was going there was for the money and
I didn't like it I did comedy I did
comedy for free for [__] 20 years for
free I would pop up and do a set 20
minutes so money was never the thing I
always knew the money would come
but somewhere along the line when things
started getting busy and the comedy took
off guys from like 2016 2017
. I was writing I was trying to be the
Best comedian I can but I got to be
honest I wasn't enjoying it I don't know
why some people I enjoy the struggle I
always have you know it got too easy I
was getting audiences that were coming
to see me I could say whatever I want
and get a laugh so it just seemed a
little off and that's why when I shot my
special for Netflix that [__] thing
was off because I knew that I couldn't
go to The Comedy Store they were going
to laugh no matter what if I went to The
Comedy Store and just got up there and
hit myself in the head with the Yellow
Pages they would laugh [__] 15
minutes that's how that place was
mentally programmed so I started taking
chances and going down to the Laugh
Factory in Long Beachwood
there's a problem with the Laugh Factory
in Long Beach is that nobody laughs at
nobody down there those people going
there for free they just sit there
waiting for a free drinking [__] and I
would go to Flappers in Burbank and they
have a little bit more
I don't know younger Burbank Yuppie
crowd so my sex wouldn't be good in
there in fact whenever I go in there I
definitely walk through people if there
was 30 in Burbank I'd walk through
people and I'd always hit two or three
you know like oh my god did he really
just say that I'm like yeah I said that
but I didn't enjoy doing that no more I
didn't enjoy
listen I enjoyed the planes you know I
love the airports and [__] I love the
towns I was going to
but the whole stand-up thing was just it
wasn't working for me at the time so I
wanted to give it a breathe that's why I
was so [__] excited when this uh
residency opened up in New York City
because it was the six month residency
that's it no more no less and again we
covered it we go we're gonna do all
[__] six months you're gonna do
Pennsylvania uh Philadelphia
and then I want you to sit take a month
off
and I want you to really [__]
evaluate what you felt and that's fair
with me that's tremendous with me we
never talked about a movie coming up we
never talked about TV this whole thing
was how I could be better adapt and be a
better comedian if I wanted to go that
route and so far I'm having a good time
in New York it's fun the drives are fun
seeing Mike and everybody down the Green
Room is [__] great do I want to do it
every weekend no but I enjoy doing it
the one you know when's the next one's
on a Wednesday the one uh Wednesday or
the one date a month that's what I
really enjoyed
but I got to tell you what that came out
of it that came out of us working like a
team and that was perfect you know and I
really enjoyed that's what we did that
that's all we discussed there was
nothing else that was really bothering
me I could sit here and tell you this is
bothering me that nothing was bothering
me I just wanted to get to the bottom of
what I why I was feeling how I was about
stand-up comedy but then I read
something when I did the last uh ad on
Monday
I read a very interesting line that
pitch
you know they alternate pitches
and this line has always been [__] uh
it's always made me raise my eyebrow
that
sometimes you can fix that on a problem
for so long that you don't take the time
to find the solution
you know I thought about that line
and what they meant by that
I had a little situation a couple nights
ago I was having a conversation with a
friend of mine one of the parents and
his wife and I was talking about a
situation
just a an LA something that had happened
that the guy never [__] uh
didn't have the balls to talk to us
anymore he [__] up but he decided just
to
and he told my wife just like we were
talking about I don't know a couple
weeks ago
and he told my wife at the last practice
he goes you know I've been watching Joey
and I think Joey but I think Joey has a
little PTSD
from LA
and
he told my wife I thought about it and
I'm like she goes are you upset I go not
at all
I go holy [__]
that seems about right
oh my God how can I Outsider come up
with the answer I was looking for
I I knew I've been a little upset at
times not angry or really upset but just
like what the [__] was that
when he said that to me I [__] called
him I'm like hey man that is the most
brilliant thing anybody has said about
me
I go what made you say that and he goes
Joey we go to Dennis we take the kids to
[__] ice cream we play softball
together with the kids
and he goes I gotta tell you something
right me and my wife admire you because
you're so old school you stick to your
values this is what you want to do you
know and the people that you admire the
people how you treat people and how they
treat you around and how you admire
people in that way he goes that's a very
old school thing
people don't do that no more and it
[__] it hit me in the head like Jesus
Christ this guy got me figured out and I
tell you what I thought back then I
thought back to when
the night Rogan called me
the pandemic was in full [__] Force I
hadn't seen him in [__] months you
know wasn't until like July or or June
when I did the podcast and it was
[__] it was very uncomfortable you
know with the [__] covet I was
nervous
but I'll never forget that we spoke like
two months after that it had to be like
July and he called me up one night it'd
be 11 o'clock and he goes Joe you got a
minute he goes I'm moving to Austin
and
I'd like to buy you and Brian a house
and get our lives together down here and
do all this [__] he wanted to open up a
club and he had great ideas and you know
I love Joe I love Joe and if it would
have been any other time in my life
there would have been no hesitation he
got 100 200 million from [__] Spotify
he offered me a little [__] Chateau
in Austin and [__] raising Ducks
whatever the [__] it was I'm like this
sounds perfect this would have sounded
Perfect 10 years ago
but I go now
I'm going home I use those exact words
I'm going home
and he's like why the [__] do you want
to do that and I'm like bro
I just gotta go home for a while you
know I really just gotta go home
and he kept saying why why why my answer
at the time was we got this covid we got
[__] going on we don't know where we're
going
and I think that it's hard enough being
out here by yourself with no family it
was just three of us Steve Simone Lee
Eric Rocha the Agostino we you know it
was
uh I go it's not a time to be out here
[__] around with our family and
without
now you guys will say to me well you
consider Joe your family you consider
Bert and all those guys my family then
my family and I love them dearly those
guys and I love
Felicia who's going to be at the show
next Wednesday I love George Perez will
also be at the show next Wednesday I I
love these guys and that in no way was I
disrespecting them
but I tell you what my big problem was
my
me saying I wanted to go home was
another word for me to go
I wanted to be around my people
I wanted to be it has been you know 23
in L.A
two in Seattle and [__] 12 in Boulder
and Aspen and Colorado and prison I've
had enough
I've had enough for for 30 years I've
been sucking in other ideals and
learning learning honest to God you
learn you can't be a [__] gorilla and
live in Aspen and you can't be a gorilla
and live in Boulder they'll throw you in
jail like they did to me and it teaches
you how to be a little soft out or be
more compassionate with people and then
you go to a place like Seattle where it
rains every day and they're still upset
about [__] uh Nirvana and you know
yeah we don't know what we're gonna do
without Chris Cornell or whatever or uh
you know Nirvana or whatever and and
that was a complete different head and I
imposed my will I did the best I could
you know to [__] uh make it happen
but at the same time you're not home
you're not around your people
you know and I'm not talking about you
who's a slice of stupid [__] pizza or
some potato chips that's that's
superficial [__]
I was looking to get back to normal I
just wanted my life
I didn't want to think about that stupid
[__] no more a movie a a spot I gotta
take a plane I was over with but I think
what pissed me off the most
was just the people I was done I was I
was not used to what I had been around
for the last 20 years I got to be honest
here I sit back now and I won't tell you
who
but there's 15 people that I left in La
that I was friends with that under any
other circumstances any part of my life
I would never be friends with these
people
like I would have never allowed in my
house 20 years ago
naughty never not never I mean I
wouldn't did not want these [__]
people around that's and when I got here
Our Lives
[__] ended
those people I'm talking about do not
contact me at all
that was it's crazy and I'm not listen I
talked to Theo
Bert calls from time to time Tom calls
from time to time Bill you know these
are all great guys
but then again I always felt like an
outsider there
I always felt kind of alone because
you know I always had to explain my
[__] my Mo whenever I did something
because I was [__] pissed off I
always had to explain why I had done it
do you not understand you're not are we
not looking at the same [__] thing
here we're not looking at the same
[__] thing here you know
for [__] eight years I went on the
road with Joe Rogan I can tell you
honest to God let's just stay
conservatively from 98 to 2007.
until Joe went on the maxim tour and he
met Tom and uh Eddie Murphy's brother I
was on the road with Joe constantly I
dedicate I didn't care he took care of
me he nourished the funny
and he was great to work with he was my
dog I didn't care what date I didn't
care where it was I'm coming
but every [__] time we landed in a
city to my mother's [__] grave to My
Daughter's Eyes I'll swear on a [__]
stack of Bibles every [__] City every
[__] weekend I'm trying to get Ari on
here next weekend to promote his new CD
that's coming out in the second and I'll
run it by Ari there wasn't a [__]
where somebody
at the jungle high or a manager at a
club or another comic would bring that
comic over to Joe and go Joe this guy
wants to tell me his story what's the
story
about a year ago I was an emcee and
Carlos put me on stage and I did a joke
about plumbing and a year later I saw it
on Carlos HBO special or something to
that effect
we heard that same story every [__]
weekend when we went out every [__]
weekend when we went out we heard some
[__] come over to us and the
stories were real they were true these
people were not making these stories up
and it was always a feature act an MC
act it was always something like that
and I'm not saying nothing bad about it
but I'm just telling you what we [__]
witnessed okay
every weekend
I still remember being in Miami a comic
down there I got robbed we went to uh
Columbus a comic dad got robbed by car
it was constant okay then in 2000 you
know now they were talking about them at
the store he was doing [__] at the store
like he did a Christmas [__] show
Carlos and he hired four comics and the
show started at eight and the first
comic didn't go on stage till 11 30.
Carlos stayed up there for three and a
half hours you know it was just things
that you do as a shitty [__] comic a
shitty person and I have nothing against
Carlos I'm just trying to make a point
here I don't I don't have nothing
against callers
this is this is history so you guys can
learn from this and then we got back to
LA and and you know every other weekend
every other [__] club the the comedy
magic club whatever you would hear it
again Carlos don't my joke it was like
he stole everybody's [__] joke and
then he was causing Havoc at the store
and then he robbed Ari's [__] joke
about the immigration the war okay
so now you guys all saw that [__]
tape okay
he went up there on a Saturday night
took the mic from him whatever the [__]
happened I wasn't there but listen to
the Applause from the comics in the back
listen to the audience listen to all
that [__]
people I mean
you know it's like right now people
[__] about biting by no goodbyes no
good we can't wait we can't wait and
then we got some Chinese president and
you guys start bitching you know you you
got rid of Biden I mean what the [__] do
you wire it's people are never satisfied
so what happened a week after that went
down
after a week
of for eight years people coming up to
Joe Rogan not just me not you know in
front of me that was 22 more
Rogan got labeled as like a bad guy
he got thrown out of the store
his agency left him and after about a
week Comics were like there was supposed
to be a boycott at The Comedy Store
Mitchy Shaw called and said whoever boy
catch me is out of the store the boycott
was ended nobody fought for Joe Rogan
nobody did nothing let me tell you
something I paid attention to that
that irked me for [__] years that was
one of the reasons I stopped going to
the store that was one of the reasons
why I got away from Comics I said if
they do that to him what will they do to
me
so for eight years this poor kid
everybody went to him every weekend and
when I have Ari on here we'll go over
this every weekend they went after Joe
and Carlos felt my bed Carlos I'm in
therapy now you know it was every
[__] weekend so finally the guy
sticks up for everybody and everybody
just walked away from him he got thrown
out of them he got banned from the store
and that's why I said I don't need to go
down there anymore this is the [__]
common take let's go to [__] uh 10
years later
I'm not at the store no more but every
weekend I keep hearing about this
[__] dumbass [__] comedian that
keeps doing stupid [__] up at the store
dumbass [__] we don't need to
mention his name why give him the
[__] satisfaction
a [__] goes down there he's
laying claims he's bumping people he's
calling the booker who can't go up
before me just [__] that you wouldn't
get away with that only a shitty human
being would do to other Comics so you
considered your friends that's why today
the guy has no [__] friends because
he [__] on every one of his friends he's
out there living in Vegas by himself who
gives a [__]
but this guy would always cause havoc
and every week I would [__] hear
something or every two weeks this
[__] did this first off he went
at me one night and I was all coked up
with the talent coordinator and I didn't
know what they were talking about so
before I lost my [__] cocaine and had
to go to jail I let it slide it's not
till I got sober that I went down there
next day and I go what the [__] were you
[__] talking about and that's
when I realized what they were trying to
do and I said you know what I don't need
this in my life no more ten years later
I go back to the store and he's down
there [__] laying claims again I
don't say nothing to the guy until one
night I hear that he's calling the
[__] phone booth telling them not to
put Joe up to let him go up before Joe
because who does that
who [__] does that
it's like dog I haven't laughed harder
in years but this is how [__] up the
world is okay
so Marky Wahlberg made a video
on Instagram
because he was supposed to go to a gym
in North Carolina some bum [__] place at
3 30 in the morning and there was nobody
there to greet him
so he made a video and it became a Yahoo
story because Marky Wahlberg wanted to
work out on a Saturday night or whatever
[__] was at 3 30 in the morning and
he made an appointment and nobody was
there he made a [__] are you [__]
kidding me go do jumping jacks you
stupid [__] I know your cat but
go run go do something you're gonna make
a video and [__] out of [__] gym
because you want to lift weights at
three in the [__] morning go [__]
yourself you're a millionaire go to the
hotel like everybody else do curls swim
in the pool I don't give a [__] but this
is where we've gotten to this is the
mind of the celebrity I'm here standing
here and I like Marty Wahlberg I love
his movies I used to see him at church I
saw him at cryotherapy yeah I'm here at
3 30 in the morning and I want somebody
to open up the gym go [__] yourself I
wouldn't have you called me and said
monkey Wahlberg is going to the gym at 3
30. you need to be down there listen I
don't care if Jesus was coming with a
Band 3 30 in the morning come at seven
like everybody else 3 30 in the [__]
morning
oh Jesus Christ but if they can't be
different
I don't work out in the afternoon
I work out at 3 30 in the morning okay
so that's what these [__] at so
back to the story I get back to the
store this guy still calls for [__]
Havoc now he's angry because we're down
there and he's talking behind our back
he's talking [__] on The Comedians and
one day I asked him what the [__] was up
Joe asked me how come the store was
better on the podcast and I laid it on
them because that [__] don't go
down there no more he's a punk ass [__]
and all hell broke loose and I went
after the guy online [__] you his wife
got involved calling me [__] names I
called her a [__] [__] and next thing
you know
everybody's happy thank God people
coming to me that's the way to go after
them thank you man that guy was a dick
and a week later I'm hearing from
[__] young Comics man
that was wrong how you did that
even one of the guys that was telling me
like inside information about him came
to me he's like man
and I never forget what I said to a man
I can't believe you're a little rough on
him I go if you would have had balls to
do it
I wouldn't have been in that position
I would have been in that position but
even that whole calling out thing or
whatever I stuck with Joe man Joe got
thrown out of there I don't need to be
down there these are things that people
from home do not people from that's the
mentality that's how awful one and one
for all who's your best friend not the
guy who's talking [__] about it the guy
that's sitting next to you in the
[__] cell that's your best friend
when I look up he's sitting next to you
he took a [__] chance too he didn't
give a [__] about anything and this is
like that day when they say that to me
like ah you were a little [__] heavy
on them well if you would have done your
job
I wouldn't have been here but all you
[__] wait for somebody to do
your job and then you condemn them
I was sick of all that [__] I was sick
of every time you you know from the
[__] Carl's Jr commercial when I had
to go out that director wait that's the
first time that happened to me that used
to happen to me every [__] week with
people who would have an uppity hand
like they think they're ugly they're
battling oh my God we we just came from
eating a hummus pancakes wait a second
wait a second you just can't eat hummus
with chips you're eating hummus [__]
pancakes
foreign
so when I said I wanted to go home
didn't necessarily mean that I wanted to
come back to Jersey and jump up and down
with these yahoos
it meant that I wanted to get together
with people that looked at life the same
way I looked at that wouldn't sell their
soul for a [__] commercial or for an
Instagram post or that [__] gets old
guys that's all I wanted to do
so that line and [__] on the better
hope thing really [__] blew my
[__] mind when it all came to
fruition I'm not pushing therapy today
I'm just telling you what worked for me
and I'm telling you what I got out of
therapy after a year and a half that I
needed to come home I needed to think
the way I used to think without people
saying to me that's the wrong way to
think you shouldn't have said that you
know you should have said no you have to
say it this guy's a [__] jerk off
these people out of their [__] mind
so
I'm happy that I came full circle with
the therapy I'm very happy that
I'm at the place I'm at I got uh four
more shows left per Dana's instructions
and then we're going to reevaluate she
gave me her number she gave me an email
if I ever run into a spot
you know it just worked out great for me
and I'm I'm apologizing because for
years I came on a podcast with Lee and
sometimes with Mike and sometimes with
Felicia
and I didn't put down therapy but I
wasn't very optimistic about it I think
I went into it not knowing what I was
going to get
I got the answer when I wanted but I
also got
the whole motivation of what got me back
here I wasn't you know whenever I say la
or the Hollywood scene I am not
condemning people all the clubs or the
restaurants I went to I had some good
friends in L.A that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about the
mindset that is La when you're in the
entertainment business
I learned something else last week that
I want to apologize for
listen man
I've said some crazy [__] in my time and
God knows what motivated it God knows
you know God knows you know something
happened early in the day something
happened two weeks ago something
happened four years ago
you know I've never been put on meds uh
to control who I am or what I am I do
take an anxiety medication to help me
feel better to help me not [__] sweat
bullets every day and it's worked along
with the therapy my working out my
[__] worker Mike doing movies being a
parent I got it all to work for me
from time to time I say [__] on the
podcast that I look at the initial but
then I more [__] happens and I don't
look at
you know what's that expression you won
the war but you lost a battle or you you
lost a battle but you won the war you
know
a couple weeks right came on and I said
what I felt that that Kanye West guy was
he just stopped taking his [__] meds
guys he either that mixed with wanting
to get attention mixed with just wanting
to be heard and common retardation God
knows what he was saying and I
I tried to just you know calm it down a
little bit like and he doesn't need for
me to calm it down I just try to lay it
down in my terms the guy's got mental
health issues you know I noticed that
all the Jewish people in California went
up in arms and not one Jew in Jersey
said something you know what I'm saying
with tough Jews down here but Jaylen Lee
Curtis a father was Spanish her father
was Jewish and she was crying for two
days you know so that's when I read that
[__] that [__] bothers me because really
you were crying for two days over Kanye
West's [__] but everybody has a
different [__] uh whatever
then I thought about I spoke to a friend
of mine some things happened I guess
that you know he said stuff
and all of a sudden last weekend in L.A
and I've heard this from a few people
that all these iodine Nazi groups and
all these [__] hate groups started
coming out on the 405 and the 10 and
that passing out [__] uh
they're passing out uh flyers and
Beverly Hills you know you know guys
again
I I don't know what's going on in the
political Arena I don't care I just deal
with people how they treat me on a daily
basis you know
I have a lot of Jewish friends and I
don't the statements I made about Kanye
one of them call him and he goes Joey I
didn't get mad at you but Jesus Christ
you you're letting them go off with the
retardation card I go listen man
the world is not in good shape right now
I don't know why he made those
statements but whatever the [__] you
know
just we're gonna be fine you know it
doesn't [__] matter but
you know I learned something I called
one of my buddies from La called me and
I go can you believe
CAA canceled you know got rid of Kanye
this is like yesterday or the day before
and uh he gonna show you they had to he
goes even CAA who's you know they're the
top agency in the world they gave him
like a week
the game like a week they didn't cut him
when he made the first Jewish remarks
they didn't they they came like a week
they said you know he's off this meds or
whatever I and what made them cut them
to hate that all of a sudden arose in
Beverly Hills and in California not
California as a whole but in Hollywood
the the hate that came on and the
freeways and the passing of flyers and
people are saying [__] to people
but he also told me a story about the
Mayoral race in L.A that one of the guys
is Jewish I mean it's just
and you know what I learned I learned
that
not only listen I sit there every night
just like you guys and I watch some sort
of the news maybe it's like Channel 12
the local Jersey thing for the weather
and for the last year they've been
talking about the capital rights right
the January 6th
January 6 January 6. and I'm sitting
there and right when I was I understood
when I got the thing about Kanye I was
thinking about it
and I saw the thing about January 6 and
it [__] hit me
it [__] hit me like
listen
I grew up just like you guys watching TV
watching the news listening to watching
movies listening to music I never
like I don't know I looked up to like
Bruce Lee and Charles Bronson but if
these guys came on Twitter
or social media and said jump off a
bridge
I don't think me and my friends would
have jumped off a bridge as much as we
liked Bruce Lee you know what I'm saying
like at that age at the age of 10 when
he died I don't think so
you know when you're a high profile
person I.E Kanye I.E Trump I even Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan is the king of this
when you say things then that perceived
of like when Mike says something and
when I say something
the following is so big that you got to
assume the following is that big that
half of them are off their [__]
rocker
and they'll do whatever the [__] you're
talking about you know with Kanye I saw
that he got all these people [__]
fired the [__] up not two or three
people not Michael Rappaport or you know
oh [__] Howard Stern I'm talking this
guy got people on the streets fired up
it's you know as he got people in these
cities flying up at least La I'm not
talking about cities plural city
at least L.A fired up well now I
understand what happened when Trump when
he went off on the sixth or the fifth or
whatever and people went down there
you know people went down there now I
understand when these [__] people
went after Joe with the misinformation
stuff
because whether it was right or was
wrong
people were [__] gonna do it anyway
when when [__] Trump said to shoot
bleach
remember during the pandemic he's in the
drink drink bleach and like 80 [__]
people turned up in emergency rooms with
[__] a bottle of bleach hey my
[__] throat don't work no more you're
like what the [__] that was just a
[__] thing he said not to do it you
know and people [__] did it so it's
scary that when somebody in a high
profile SP like the [__] you know a
lot of people don't have that like if
Jimmy Kimmel was to say something nobody
would give a [__] but Trump Kanye Rogan
you know I'm not mad at Joe for anything
I love what Joe was doing
but I understand now why people were
scared which they shouldn't have been
scared of at all he was given the best
information that he had at the time
just [__] weird how people
you know Pink Floyd uh wrote that album
animals as part of a book that George
Orwell wrote or something like that I
have to look it up I think it's animal
farm and George Orwell and guys
if you listen to the lyrics to sheep
we are falling right into what they said
on the album animals I had albums on the
other night I was just making notes like
I was writing some type of stupid joke
and I'm like these people are same
what people today are becoming worry the
sheep dogs are [__] pigs
you know when I see these politicians
arguing every day there's you know these
why are people arguing on podcast guys
what are all these podcasters fighting
about the same biggie [__] Tupac no
more this ain't East Coast I don't it's
just the world's going a [__] up place
but it's always great
to learn and say wow that's why these
things happen I had a I had a great week
this week as far as I'm concerned I
learned about two things I learned about
myself and I learned about
how yeah you have to be a little [__]
uh careful with your words when people
look at you in that listen I've never
had people look at me like that and I
don't want people to [__] do what I
say I destroy an idea and if it works
for you you works for you if it doesn't
I [__] get it I'm not I don't know
nothing about nothing I'm a [__]
ex-felon I'm a high school [__]
Dropout and I have a hard time waking up
in the morning but I did do a lot of
good things with my life and I'm really
happy about that I'm happy that I went
to a therapist and I ate my words
and I'm happy that I'm here [__] drug
free drama-free smoking some reefer
listen man I took [__] two I haven't
taken those mushrooms since the weekend
the sillies that I love I took three of
them last night and 400 milligrams of
ABX Edibles let me tell you something I
laid down last night it was tremendous
because I don't know if my cat knew that
I was on mushrooms I think she [__]
did these cats are geniuses
because I'm laying there last night now
she crawls on me this way I mean
so she's on on my side usually I pop my
left hand up and I scratch her nose with
it
and since she's here I can't reach
around to scratch her back
so what I do is I slide my hand down so
she slides into this pocket right here
at the edge of the bed and I could
scratch him we could both be comfortable
but she's scared she thinks I'm gonna
grab her and give her a bunch of kisses
so every time she slides she puts her
[__] brakes on with the nails and she
flies on the other side and then she'll
stand and let me pet her but if she's
sleeping and I lay her and I bet her
sides her belly is so so off the hair
and [__] she loves it and then I can
scratch her neck from underneath with my
long hand and she goes [__] ape [__]
and those leaks she sneezes and [__]
[__] tremendous last night I tried to
lure in there
and she got she left she went and got
something to eat and I'm about to fall
asleep the mushrooms are [__] kicking
them I got a thousand different thoughts
on my coconut
and all of a sudden herself
she came over and slid there I was in
shock so I got to scratch your sides her
face whatever and then I'd heard [__]
call she just popped up and got on me
and sat here for a little while and I
was falling asleep and then about one I
woke up
I had something against my [__] back
I'm like I can't turn I mean it was
right there in the wedge I couldn't turn
and [__]
and I [__] look over and how do you
think the [__] is laying sideways so I
could scratch your side but close to me
and she's you know how many times she's
done that in [__] 12 years
none that [__] knew those [__]
mushrooms are kicking because it made me
think why is she there
why is she laying on there and [__]
baffle me so I actually had to get up go
to the bathroom and I came back even
though the blanket was on top of you
know when you flipped the blanket she
she didn't [__] move when I put the
blanket back on top of me she stayed
right there and I'm like this [__]
knows I'm on the mushrooms you yeah she
[__] knows anyway that was our
podcast for today
I learned something last week and uh
that's what I'm excited about listen we
got a podcast coming on Monday
but I'm starting to shoot this movie
next Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday so
if you don't get a second one never fear
Uncle Joe is here I'll still be putting
on the Joey Diaz project patreon podcast
and I'll figure something out with Mike
to give you guys a podcast I got a show
in the city next Wednesday
so uh yeah that's that's my schedule I'm
very sorry about this guys but you will
have the Monday morning [__]
breakdown
don't forget the show next Wednesday and
I love you [__] have a happy
Halloween
be careful for fentanyl when you say
Trick or Treat make sure you say no
fentanyl with that treat [__]
they're gonna be a lot of fentanyl then
they just get 10 pounds of fentanyl on
the Mexican border or something like
that a lot of fentanyl for the holidays
growth give out apples and if you
[__] eat candy make sure it comes
with a number on it you know what
Chelsea [__] came from have a happy
Halloween be safe I love you
[__] and now for a word for my
[__] sponsor Jack
all right I want to thank you
[__] for uh listening on a
beautiful Thursday morning after being
patient with me before we leave listen
you know I like to trim my nut sack and
my dick you know I'm a fat dude so you
gotta you need help from every [__]
angle you get if not your balls starts
smelling funny and whatnot but that all
changed because manscaped is here to
keep your little candy cane smooth or
your candy corn candy cane is Christmas
what the [__] is wrong with me listen
trimming ball hair is fun in fact you
should let your girlfriend trip your
nutsack with manscape's performance
package 4.0 got it all the lawnmower 4.0
body trimmer and weed whacker and the
nose and ear trimmer it features skin
safe technology to protect the delicate
holes plus they're all waterproof so you
can shave in the shower and it has an
LED light so even if the power goes off
you can still [__] scrape your nut
sack off the [__] roof manscape even
threw in two free gifts to that package
boxes and the shed travel bag so I'm
Gonna Get You twenty percent of 20.
before the holidays and free shipping
with Coach Joey at manscape.com again
that's 20 off from free shipping with
code Joey at manscape.com manscape clear
out the leaves and let that [__] tree
trunk shine you [__] suckers the show is
also brought to you by this plate listen
they're here at that class to your
[__] life and daddy room in your
house they have millions of designs and
they feature gaming movies and Comics
plus they have designs from Star Wars
Netflix and many more I love it my Bruce
Lee [__] tremendous I'm gonna rotate
it I think I got a Godfather too
somewhere listen it only takes 20
seconds to hang a display no power tools
needed no damages no frustrations once
you mount one you can switch it out to a
new plate in a Flash with everyone that
you buy this plate plants a tree now
that's a company you could do business
with click the link in the description
to see some of my favorite displays and
save up to 29 get 25 off when you buy
one or two get 29 off when you buy three
or more discounts will be automatically
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use Joey when you visit
display.com again that's displayed.com
code Joey or click in the link notes
just when you thought it was tape it's
time to sling dick with [__]
confidence that's where Bluetooth comes
in Bluetooth is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis
but a chewable tablet or at a fraction
of the cost take them any time
and an empty stomach full stomach be
ready whenever the opportunity arises
listen I love blue shoe why comes in
little packages you put them in your
wallet nobody knows nothing you see a
[__] pigeon on the pond you put in
your little [__] water bottle and
you're drinking and that's it and guess
what the process is simple you sign up
at bluetooth.com again at bluetooth.com
because so with one of our licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive the prescription
within days the best part is nobody
knows nothing no doctor's visits no
awkward conversations at the [__]
pharmacy no line you don't have to smell
this [__] guy in front of you
Bluetooth tablets are made in the US of
a and shipping the discrete package so
if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help it's time to sling
dick the holidays are coming everybody
wants a present try Bluetooth for free
when using promo code Joey just pay five
dollars for shipping that's
bluetooth.com code Joey for your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
important safety information and I want
to thank Bluetooth for sponsoring to
join along with manscape
to help display
CBD lion it's been a great week I love
you [__] stay black and I'll see
you Monday morning Tip Top [__]
Magoo
we did it